[Music]
hi everybody welcome to the data science
hangout
if you're joining for the first time
it's great to meet you i'm rachel
dempsey i'm the host of the data science
hangout
if you're if this is your first time
what is this it's an open space for the
whole data science community to connect
and chat
about data science leadership questions
you're all facing
really just what's going on in the world
of data science
so we really want to create spaces where
everybody can participate and we can
hear from everyone
so there's a few ways that you can ask
questions today
you can always ask questions anonymously
through
the slido link which robert will share
in the chat in just a second here
you can raise your hand on
zoom and i could just call on you
or you could also put questions into the
zoom chat
and if you want me to read them out loud
instead of you you can just put a little
star next to your question too
but i do like to reiterate we want to
hear from everybody no matter your level
of experience or the industry that you
work in so feel free to
to use the chat there ask questions any
way that that works for you
but i am so happy to
be joined by my co-host for today
joseph corson and joseph i might need a
lesson in saying your last name
manager of data science at prakagia
and joseph i'd love to have you
introduce yourself and maybe share a
little bit about the work that you do
sure well thank you for having me rachel
um happy to be here and thank you all
for joining as well um yeah my name is
joe uh you did pronounce my last name
correctly it is corson
uh you know kudos there um but yeah i am
the manager of data science at burkagia
my role primarily is you know delivery
engagement for um
you know our clients uh making sure
consultants are kind of on track um i
help out with a little bit of code
review here or there
but for the most part i'm kind of a
deliverables manager
i have oversight on progression as well
for consultants
making sure they're on the correct
trajectory for their career path as well
internal development is big
so that's kind of a little bit about my
role
awesome thank you it'd be great to hear
a little bit more about what the team
looks like as well and how many data
scientists there are
sure
um so i do manage a little bit of
variety of data scientists um there's
some bioinformatician genomicists on the
team um i have a few data analytics
stragglers in there too
um but yeah so primarily i manage a team
of 16
that's going to be bumping up to 18
right now
their work kind of varies depending on
their role and expertise some people do
ml ops ml engineering
there's some data engineers as well on
that team that specialize either in
azure aws
we have some google cloud platform gurus
on the team as well
uh but yeah day-to-day a lot of variety
within the team and kind of the role in
general
thank you i see robert put a question
into the chat
off the bat
and this is one we used to ask in the
beginning
so what are you super excited about
right now in data science
well you know just
kind of the opportunities right um there
are so many problems in the world that
data science can solve um whether that
be supply chain um you know cancer
research uh
you know there's a lot of improvements
that can be made in the world today and
i think you know that comes through
automation initiatives but eventually
you need an understanding of the data
set in itself
so first and foremost i think
you know we identify a problem uh we
look for a little bit of a solution to
the problem and then um kind of let that
be self-sufficient right so
it has a lot of opportunity to help
awesome sam i know you put a question to
the chat um if you want to jump in and
ask that live
hey joseph just a quick question so what
led you to join leadership and become a
manager
of data scientists
yeah you know it's it's a little bit of
a difficult leap i would say uh you know
i
found myself being a little bit
passionate about you know diving into
some code uh understanding a problem at
hand but those don't really change too
much you're just a little bit more hands
off you have more of a variety of
problems but the thing that led me to
help others is you know
exactly that right there's more of an
opportunity to help develop people
round out some skill sets identify maybe
some weaknesses some strengths where
others can actually help
one another as well so that's a little
bit of part of my role as well so that's
the most satisfying and what really led
me to take on a little bit more
leadership
and did you say
six before 16
16
16 wow we are uh we are a fast growing
firm uh last year i believe we doubled
in size uh we're on a similar pace this
year so um i imagine that you know kind
of reduces over time uh but for now
that's that's the total
can i ask you how do you
manage
professional development
and and keep track with 16 different
people
yeah
so it's a little bit challenging but i
think you
kind of face similar challenges with
smaller size teams as well right so uh
with a with a smaller firm we are kind
of considered a startup so for the most
part um it brings about more opportunity
so more senior people they look for more
of those leadership roles those tech
lead roles as well um
just kind of a mix between that batch uh
but
for the most part the more junior
analysts uh or data scientists um they
all have a little bit of a pain point
where they need to develop round out
some skills um
for me i
try to see where where people sit
currently benchmark that a little bit
look for areas of improvement i conduct
one-on-ones i try to
you know be on top of the day-to-day
workload for them as well i don't want
them being overwhelmed uh gradual
progression is the is probably the
easiest route to take for most people
so uh daily one-on-one check-ins uh
you know check-ins for the project as
well um a lot of a lot of my calendars
filled with meetings
i see there are a lot of questions
coming in the chat around management too
and and one was a follow-up to sam's
question zack do you want to jump in
yep candy um so yeah it was just it
seems a lot of questions about this like
of course traditionally
uh
as you progress in your career you turn
into a manager
uh i was just wondering do you miss the
coding side of it i looked at new
linkedin you're a data scientist for
about a year
so
uh before moving up so regime is just
natural career progression
uh but you said you weren't very
hands-on these days i was wondering what
you thought about that
yeah so there's opportunities um you
know not within your daily uh profession
to still establish some professional
development if you're looking to enhance
your technical abilities uh part of
being a manager as well is you know
being experienced with or at least have
a
baseline understanding of some of the
technologies that's currently in
development right so
moving to more cloud platforms i think
i've been learning a little bit more
about data engineering upping my my
linux skills as well on the side
uh so it doesn't you know fall off the
table uh you still want to make sure
you're up to date with the latest
technology understanding how some of
that works going through some tutorials
as well um so i don't think it really
just completely falls off the table it's
just not part of your day-to-day life
anymore
but there's always opportunity the
continued curiosity is
a big thing that i don't think ever
really leaves you
i like that continued curiosity
i see andreas you had a similar
question i think it was maybe answered
in that but do you have any follow-up
questions i think it was mostly answered
yeah i was just wondering the the mix of
managing and actually still hands-on
technical parts and
if you
sort of
have a
deliberate way of doing this or is it
just whatever happens happens
um
well i think it's kind of where the
company is at as well where i look to
round out some of my skill sets um you
know if it is ml ops understanding how
pipeline development works uh eventually
data scientists get a firm understanding
of you know statistics and you know that
that technical knowledge doesn't leave
you uh too quickly uh thankfully uh but
the programmatic side of things helping
out with code there's always going to be
somebody on the team that is going to be
more proficient at you at coding uh so i
don't think part of my my role day to
day uh will entail um being that expert
anymore i would say but you still need
to have a little bit of a firm base as
to how things work in a
high level
i love all these questions that are
coming in immediately everybody's ready
to go today
i see there was a anonymous question
that was about your background and what
led you to this field
sure um
you know i
want to point back to curiosity i would
say
through my progression i think i started
off doing some economics uh
during during my initial masters i think
that was in business intelligence and
analytics um see at the time analytics
was still relatively new
i'm showing my age a little here
but uh you know you got you got some
some deep dive understanding of how ai
would work um you know understanding
some python implementation um
but the continued development i would
say for me is is i wanted to get more um
i want to take a little bit of a step
back i would say so statistics is pretty
much a lot by hand you might use sas a
little bit
r is very common as well uh for
statistical programming but the in the
inferential side um you know i was
trying to understand things from a
business perspective um
i wanted to take a little bit of a step
back like see what i can get from some
of these uh
assumptions you know tests that you
perform
um
so i would say my progression is just
hopping around a little bit seeing what
fits well uh you know trying to master a
skill set at a given period um
continuously moving forward i would say
this is the biggest
uh challenge where's where's the next
step for you and your career as well
so
it's kind of my my progression
thanks joe
there's a lot of great questions coming
in in the chat too and and libby i see
you had a comment about the job
landscape today would you want to jump
in and ask that question
sure so i've been talking to lots of
people um on
teams around you know kind of in our our
space where
they're really hiring just seniors
they're not really looking for anybody
who's junior because they don't have the
seniors in place to grow juniors yet
and i've been curious if that's been a
challenge that maybe you faced in your
org
yeah i mean
it's definitely a pain point i would say
getting getting more senior people in
there um
but
part of the progression aspect with
larger firms is maybe these more senior
people aren't given the opportunity to
mentor more junior
analyst programmers
um so we try to give them that
opportunity uh so
internally we've tried to take some of
our senior people do a little bit of you
know a weekly hands-on coding session
with some of them understanding how
some of these data science techniques
work maybe for our
you know understanding some some new
packages that are being established in
the field i think a lot of our work
centers around bioconductor right now
but i would say you know giving those
people an opportunity uh
continuously looking is
is probably my advice but a lot of
people are just looking to to help
others in today's society so uh giving
them that opportunity showcasing that
your firm's really about that
i think will help retain and acquire
some of the key talent that you're
looking for
awesome thanks
i see steve you asked a question
earlier which i think might help provide
us all context too do you want to ask
that
uh sure yes uh just trying to understand
also what's your
what your data scientists are actually
using as a platform what phys what
hardware are you doing it in-house or is
it in the cloud
what
environments do you provide to your to
your data scientists
sure
we are consulting firms so it kind of
depends on the client um that they're in
as well um so in-house we we do have a
little bit of a playground in aws going
forward um so that's primary target for
us internally we want to continue you
know getting people acclimated with some
of these tools aws offers
you know spinning up ec2 instances is a
big thing um the parallel processing
compute so i think that's kind of the
direction we're taking internally um but
depending on the consultant it's kind of
where the firm they're allocated to uh
and the use case is there for um you
know what tools are given but most of
them are on cloud they're either azure
it seems primarily or aws given those
are our partner networks
thanks joe and and that topic there was
also an anonymous question um what's the
mix of bi tools versus coding tools at
your company and how have you navigated
the perception that they are one and the
same
yeah so
i think we we primarily have uh tableau
and microsoft power bi i think we have
more power bi uh developers than tableau
at this point
um
but
they're not going to be one in the same
tableau and you know power bi are easy
to develop you know key visuals for
business objectives i would say python
are
both of those languages are geared
towards understanding what's going on
with the data set at a given time
so when it comes to present presentation
continual integration dashboards
visualizations uh they're great
especially for automation initiatives so
we do encourage some of our data
scientists to as you know be familiar
with some of those visualization tools
they're very key for business objectives
relaying information to stakeholders um
so identifying the differences there i
would say
you
know perform some of your inferential
analysis exploratory analysis with with
code uh when you're ready to kind of
present that to somebody else uh that's
when the visualization should take
form you
really feeling the energy from everybody
in the chat today which i really needed
this morning so thank you
erin i i see you had a a comment and and
question in the chat too would you want
to jump in yeah just real quick i'll
introduce myself i'm an engineer for a
railroad maintenance company and i've
been doing that quite a while i'm a pe
and all that and recently i was paired
up with a data scientist somebody kind
of like what you've described yourself
and i was given some work to do with him
and really enjoyed it and ended up
moving to work with him i started off as
he kind of came to me with some how how
do you do this and that gave him all
these messed excel sheets and eventually
i moved to his group and now i'm in this
group and
uh it's a bit tough learning how to code
i never was taught um how to code but
it's going very well i'm just a little
curious how do you have people to work
on you who have maybe a lot of some
skills but zero coding skills and how do
you encourage them to kind of go on
their own with that sort of thing if you
do that i don't know if that's uh if you
have anybody like how i've described
myself and where i am right now and um
yeah if you have any comment then i'd be
nice to hear i know
yeah we definitely have people that are
you know unfamiliar with some semblance
of coding i think at any point in your
career you've written a formula in excel
so just learning to translate that into
you know more usable
[Music]
scripts
i would say so
how i develop people
and enhancing their programmatic
efficiency
again kind of pairing them with somebody
else but you know i think it starts with
identifying what their what their
determined career path is from their own
perspective right so some people
they want to be more statistics oriented
they want to either be you know more ml
engineering oriented right so you have
to understand like where's the focal
point for their career going forward um
what's the pain point that they have
right now uh what's the quickest way to
kind of upskill them and that's some in
that sense
um
so the most recent case that i have is
we had somebody that really wanted to
you know get into more of the
architectural design space uh so you
know getting them familiar with some of
the tutorials
you know just having them do some
hands-on labs i think it's more
beneficial than watching videos reading
textbooks you're actually getting you
know
down and dirty with some of the code um
and you're gonna have errors along the
way that's the most important thing
i don't think anybody's not written a
script that didn't function the first
time
uh so having an understanding that there
are going to be errors along the way um
giving them the resources that they need
uh whether whether they're a visual
learner if they do prefer textbooks
that's okay
you know some of the more stats oriented
people i would say prefer more texts
from what i've seen
more of the engineers maybe a little bit
more of the visuals documentation just a
little bit of a hybrid approach
so providing them the resources that
they need understanding where's the
initial pain point in development um and
just giving them the tools pairing them
with someone that may may have that
skill set if they don't that's okay we
can guide them and you know make sure
that they're understanding what they're
reading is actually what they're putting
into practice
yeah that's good to hear i do have a
co-worker who's a um who's helped me out
a little bit more of an entry level guy
but again knows most coding than i do
and i'm going to that conference at the
end of july too so that's um looking
forward to that very much thank you
nice so uh celine i see you have your
hand raised you want to jump in
hi sorry i'm new to this group first
time i come in anyway welcome thanks for
joining
i heard some blimps about like how to
mentor
you know new coders
i've done that a lot um and one thing
that surprises me all the time with new
coders is
they they feel uncomfortable just
googling and copy pasting
large chunks of code from the web
so that's just i know it's a silly thing
but i feel like that
unblocks new coders that you don't have
to code everything from scratch you can
literally
search it google it copy paste it and
adapt it to your problem
and yeah for some reason that's
something that that new coders
feel reluctant to do
that's a great point
i've i felt that myself
as well and i know we've talked a bit on
here about code snippets too and being
able to share with
with others across the team
i see there let me just
jump over to some of these other
questions here too javier
and notice you asked the question around
um
experience at rit
do you want to jump in there
yeah so i am graduating uh this semester
uh i am wrapping up some of my work uh
there um i think i i have my intro
course so i've already
made way through all the other material
and i'm also writing my thesis this
semester as well so
do you feel like that's helped you sort
of in your in your management role or
even just as a you know data science
team member
specifically the stats masters because i
saw that you had another masters
yeah so i think both actually do help um
i didn't really plan to you know step
into the managerial space it just seemed
to be where i was needed the most um so
i'm always willing to help out others
but
for my own progression uh the stats
masters does help
just because it's a little bit of a
different approach than say you know
machine learning engineer or a typical
data scientist is learning in school now
uh if you've you know
you've seen some of the degrees coming
up their data science business analytics
ml engineering right all of those have a
little bit more specialization um in one
key area or not
um so i would say you know a combination
of both the business intelligence and
analytics degree helps helps really
solidify the business foundation
understanding for myself
and i do like to highlight a little bit
with this development too uh some of the
data scientists it's a little bit
different way of thinking right so some
of them start off with a problem uh they
look for you know what are these key
features going into this model so i kind
of approach it from a statistical
perspective in that sense um but from a
business perspective right
uh what's our key objective that we have
can we work back from there and
establish some sort of understanding of
the data set in itself so there's
there's two ways to approach a
a problem uh one one is you know more
linear uh and then the other one's kind
of you know working your way back have
an understanding of um
you know what's our end goal here uh
what do we want to establish and how do
we how do we get to that objective so i
would say both help uh quite well uh i
think the statistics is a little bit
more
i have a little bit more of an
understanding for you know starting off
with nothing and just seeing what we can
understand from the given problem
thank you
i see there are a lot of comments around
mentorship and the way that other
people are teaching others on their team
so i just want to go back and kind of
circle around
that point as well and what celine
brought up um
but i see libby you had
a question around maybe not being as
senior but wanting to mentor people do
you want to jump in
sure i think it's more of a mental
blockage like that you have to get past
and i i think it's also something that
maybe women in data science struggle
with maybe more than men i'm not going
to generalize everybody but
it's a common feeling for me where i
think like oh i don't have anything to
give anybody else but i have the desire
to
and um
when i talk to other data scientists
that are kind of at my level below
they're
constantly telling me like you know so
much more than you let on like you're
way more capable than you're letting on
to me that you are like you have all
these things to share
but not being a senior and not being a
lead it feels like
a presumptuous thing to do to reach out
and want to to talk to other people but
i'm getting over it slowly any tips on
that would be great especially because
we all come from different backgrounds
right like
they're all things that even if we're
the same level that we have different
specializations in
really and i see um
celine had you had your hand raised as
well if that was in response to
libby's question it it was so
i find it i find that uh you know the
feel of incompetency kind i i get that
um i actually
might be interesting i actually learned
r by teaching it so i had no clue
i mostly worked with r but i had no clue
from the start but what i did do is i
had
you know people that i was teaching and
i would teach something that i just
learned and i would ask them to come
with their problems to me
and then if i couldn't solve it i had
like a person that i had established
contact with that i would go to to solve
that problem and come back to the
mentorees
and that worked for me because
you learn from other people's problems
um and you also like teach things that
you know
like are that you almost feel
comfortable with
so that was my
my structure
in the early days in the early days like
you need one contact person that you
know you can go to if you don't know
um and then you can teach what you do
know to
you know who you're mentoring and you
and they know that you can get
information if you don't have it that's
good feedback i think i need to find
that um at work that's something that
when i was in an academic setting was
really easy right like i could tutor
other people there was a big need for it
so i tutored all through grad school um
and i tutored all through undergrad too
and that was something that i did on a
weekly basis but then when i got to work
all of it stopped
i didn't have anybody to tutor there
were no assignments that they needed
help with right um
and people are a little bit less likely
maybe to reach out with specific
problems on things that they're doing
maybe they don't want to look like they
need help because this is their job this
isn't a homework assignment
um so it's definitely like a
a
shift that has to happen in the team
mindset as well for other people to be
open to it perhaps this is a great
conversation thank you so much celine
another thing that i do regularly is
when i discover something and it you
know
something new that i didn't know i
usually present it to the team
and so you know they might know it
uh but that puts a learning kind of
aspect to the team and they will put
forward stuff that they just discovered
a new package or a new you know whatever
um so i i think that also helps team
learning
for sure yeah we just implemented some
knowledge sharing sessions ourselves
trying to get into that mindset of like
everybody sharing
definitely and
i see
mike you're adding a few tips into the
chat too if you want to jump in
or i can read some of them
but a lot was around that um like
learning out loud as you both mentioned
like sharing
sharing new things that you're learning
and i think mike was pointing to
how mara
from our studio does that on twitter
but
oh there you go
yeah so i
a couple of things
i i really think there's power in
learning out loud
um
most people are experts at a very very
very narrow field and so
they are
if you learn something you can typically
pass it on to many people and they'll go
oh wow i had i hadn't known that that's
fantastic
the other thing i saw just today was
that
there was a psychology type poll about
learning and asking for help and it
found that 44 of people won't reach out
for help in case it makes them look like
they don't know what they're doing but
that means that 44 of people aren't
asking for help when they need it
so if you're ready
you know it means that
you can you can help a lot of people
because there's a huge number out there
who who really need help and are just
too afraid to kind of face up come
forward and say actually i do need some
help here
themselves that's a great point mike
the community service
i want to touch base a little bit on
this um so you gotta be mindful that you
know everybody's gonna be a little
different too in your workplace um
so you know you you can have as much
technical ability as you want but if
you're struggling to find people that
are willing to reach out for that help
um that's kind of the pain point in
itself right so it seems like you're on
track for
community involvement within the
organization but uh the culture is a big
thing um you wanna you know build
foundational skill sets but you wanna
make sure uh the transparency between
people uh is something that's you know
within the workplace too um if they're
not comfortable reaching out to a
manager that's okay um you know there
are other people that i'm sure
they can be paired with that you know
would help them with their problem so
just be mindful i would say of every
individual some people don't like to
reach out just because
it's in their personality right so you
have to have an understanding that all
people are going to be a little bit
different
but we all have similar goals right we
want to continue to move forward
continue to progress
so i think you have some some semblance
of a relationship there just based on
that
and joe how does the oh you go ahead
mike
i'm also thinking of
you know what joseph just said reminds
me of jd long's stuff about empathy
um so jd long
tweets says see mastication
or cerebral mastication and he has
presented at um our studio conference
about empathy and how if you approach
people with problems with empathy
you know folks are looking for someone
kind to come alongside and cut them some
slack and help them out
so yeah if you if you weighed in hey
look how much i know i'm gonna beat you
over the head with this you'll never win
friends
you're not gonna know it all too that's
that's part of it right uh so there's no
real reason to treat it as such i would
say
definitely
and um
i imagine you have some
you have this culture of helping each
other on your team with so many data
scientists but i'm curious what that
looks like for your team
sure um a lot of it you know it may be
segmented out a little um you know
depending on where people are located
what firm they're allocated to um but i
i do encourage you know we have some ml
tutorials going on i'm looking to
establish more of the data engineering
tutorials um but i want to foster this
community uh culture
so that's that's the biggest takeaway um
everybody has their own trajectory that
they're looking for uh you know giving
them kind of a buddy system of somebody
that's a little bit more senior
following that pathway i've already been
through that struggle um
yeah i can provide as much resource as
much guidance as i can community uh
external events are a big team builder
too
so you want to have a relationship with
people in person you want to have you
know that relationship virtually as well
for the specifics the foundational skill
sets uh
open office hours too you know they're
very they're very crucial i would say
for certain people um so all of those in
in combination i would say help kind of
falter this continual learning objective
that i'm trying to establish internally
um and
i've seen pretty good success out of it
so
yeah
awesome thank you
maybe shifting gears a little bit i see
matthew asked a question on data
engineering versus data science tasks
would you want to jump in and
add your extra context there
oh boy and you caught me just as i was
stuffing m m's in my oh no oh i went
through them
that's not a good replacement for lunch
um
yeah i guess you know in my organization
we we
i'm in an early stage data science team
and we live outside of it we're actually
a research function so it's a little bit
interesting and we're reliant on it for
data warehouse graduating into a data
lake and there's an ebb and flow there
and
we try to keep our distance from those
data management activities but at the
same time we often say okay kind of have
to go commando or have to go a little
workaround and band-aids and negotiating
that to what extent and i'm just curious
about other people's experiences with
this we're living in our own little
bubble and it's like you know the push
back the oven flow and techniques to
keep focused on the science
versus this infrastructure aspect
well
there's no easy answer i know i'm mostly
like looking to commiserate and hear
about other people's challenges i guess
sure um i mean i i think you know
everybody's gonna be working together
too um from my perspective right so the
data scientists should have an
understanding of the architecture that's
being developed right um there's
parameter checks as well dealing with
that infrastructure build so something
to keep in mind is you know
what's the intent of working with the
data so i i don't think it's just a
complete migration you want to make sure
utilities is going to be maximized as
well from your analyst data scientists
so um i would almost you know encourage
a little bit of you know overlap between
the groups uh at least for input making
sure everything's kind of
you know you want to make sure
qualification of the system essentially
is up to par uh so i think there's a
little bit of input that's needed
input and perhaps you know talking about
empathy leading going back and saying
okay look we're all working on this
together you know let's help each other
out by by actually being being a team
and being colleagues and
unfortunately that's going a long way as
opposed to staffing up
yeah
chris i saw you had some thoughts on
this in the chat too if you want to
weigh in
sure um
it's interesting because i'm just
wrapping up an engagement with a data
engineering consultancy
which we used to help our small team
uh move into the cloud some of our etl
processes
but ultimately
we are still responsible for them
our iit doesn't help we don't have data
engineering teams and
none of the companies i've been at
have had data engineering
functions we've been there so the teams
i've been on have always been
responsible for that for better or for
worse
many times for worse
sometimes for better
i've sort of developed my own
philosophies on how to do this that
would probably make data engineers eyes
roll to the back of their head
but it's about optimizing around
the way
i want to be able to work which is try
to distill us down quickly i want to
always have the data
ready at hand if i could all
anticipate the kinds of requests that
are going to come up in the future
to
front load the gathering of that data
in advance and then automate the
collection of it even if it's not
particularly sophisticated
uh and then i want to make i basically
want to minimize the time of every new
project that is spent on data collection
and data engineering
and so how you get there can be
different ways
but by optimizing to the the analytics
approach later
generally speaking um i'm able to do the
work on the projects i'm working on
pretty quickly because the the adage of
like you're going to spend 80 percent of
your time collecting the data
doesn't apply if you did the work in
advance
to build up the data sets that you're
going to need later
thanks chris
i see melody you just put a comment into
the chat too that you're experiencing
something similar
if you want to jump in
yeah um i mean not not too much to
say um that probably a lot of us have
you know experienced um or at least for
for those of us in like sort of the
government area um public health you
know is
horribly underfunded um and it is uh
just a whole other field um in the realm
of public health uh so yeah that that
has been you know definitely a struggle
for us as well
um and you know and i just put in the
chat where we're trying to focus on you
know increasing knowledge for and
training for rit teams as well
just to try to get everyone up to speed
try to you know increase
the knowledge base
and and just kind of try to get
uh you know support
in the way that we need um because it's
true i mean it you're pretty much dead
in the water if you don't have the right
infrastructure set up um and the right
people to support that infrastructure um
so
a little pug for public health make sure
you vote for more funding um so we can
all
do better here
thanks melody
i don't want to shift gears too quickly
if people have other thoughts or things
to add to to this discussion too
yeah jump in steve
i just uh comment because i come from
i'm i'm the interloper here because i'm
really a nighty person not a data
scientist person but i have to support
people who want these environments in
order to be able to do the data science
so i'm quite interested in that
that
joint that interface layer between the
users
the people that want to actually use the
products which will will implement
and how we get that working because
obviously there is a
the traditional it department isn't well
suited to doing the sorts of work which
you do
and that's where we're you know things
like devops and being a lot more
responsive to
users requirements and actually getting
users direct as we're developing the
products as we're implementing
our studio environments
getting engagement as early as possible
along with with our users is really
critical
so
as we're developing the platform and
rolling out rolling out new versions
we're continually
trying to engage with the users and say
what features do you need are you happy
with the way this looks
what extra libraries are you gonna are
you going to need
how do you want to
interact with us i.e
are you just you do you want to raise a
service ticket or do you just want to
post and post a message on a bulletin
board saying hey this library is needed
so
it's quite it's quite interesting to see
how that
how
it interfaces with
users
and it's that sort of almost like
uh developer oriented i t which is
relatively relatively new well
not that new but it's uh it's now of
greater focus
thanks steve i think we're all excited
now to ask
questions to it
if he's saying that
can i ask you what is the
what does that process look like within
your organization do you have one point
of contact on
the end user side that you work with
so we have a uh
product manager for
doing our stuff and data science
we have lots of key users scattered
about so i work for a very large
agrochemical company so we have
big central heavyweight i.t departments
but then lots of little sort of
offshoots and little group clusters of
engineers who go around to help people
so we're
more on the research side so we're
trying to in trying to sweep up users
who are interested in
our studio neo4j mango
[ __ ] and mondo
all of the things i'm trying to say can
we do this better than you're actually
doing it yourself right so we have a lot
of a lot of users who will actually
start up their own environments and get
it running and now they want to keep it
maintained and don't really have time
because they're supposed to be doing
their
their day work
so we as a sort of relatively lean team
come and leap in and say how can we
actually
make that a bit more stable environment
and have a no
so you've got the thing working now
let's take over responsibility for
patching it and making sure it's
upstairs and
also creating a community around each of
the products so we'll have a
an our studio team
teams group where people can ask
questions about our studio similarly
we'll have a focus on r and python and
other sort of like technical areas then
people can actually if they're
interested
they can join that community and engage
and hopefully some of us will be
scattered about those groups to be able
to sweep up saying
oh yeah that's an i.t related issue
which we can help with
but our problems also have that our main
big it departments
aren't interested in this sort of user
engagement
and that's really
that's we think is a big failing because
they will run a
giant gitlab server and that's great but
they don't patch it well no we're in
lab server which we patch on a regular
basis and people tend to come to us
so you can't stand up a service unless
you're willing to provide a full
service around that and that's that's
social that's that engagement with the
users
so just finishing a project is not the
end of the project
yeah
steve i think we're all gonna have to
pick your brain on on some of that
later as well too thank you
i'm learning this as i'm going along as
well so this is all
there's a lot of stuff which is you know
we're learning we're doing a big aws
project so we're rolling out our studio
with
terraform and ansible and others like
cool bits of technologies which we're
still we're learning about as we go
along
and it's very difficult to actually a
lot of this information there's bit
snippets available on the internet so
we're
we're having to work this out all all by
ourselves
so we're also
although we're a little sort of parrot
offshoot doing all this stuff we're
still also trying to learn as we go
along
yeah
thank you
and i see there is a few other anonymous
questions that came in earlier joe and
one was would love to hear a cool
success story of something you delivered
for a client
and they said i love fun i love fun data
stories
oh
um so in my previous role i would say um
was this a personal question or a
company question either
um i think it's
i think it maybe was company question
but it's probably
could be either so whatever whatever one
is most fun for you to tell how about
oh we had a we had a recent um
somebody reached out to us um a firm uh
they were working you know establishing
some on-prem servers configuring our
studio workbench trying to establish an
rstudio connect as well um they ran into
a bunch of issues eventually reached out
to us
you know to provision their ensure that
their provision servers were indeed
functioning correctly with their rstudio
workbench uh connect they could publish
with some version control as well uh
and it took us a little bit um
longer than i would say but you know
diving into the deep nitty gritty of the
problem itself um whether it be a config
file whether it be a firewall prevention
right we wanted to make sure that we we
rounded out some of these understandings
of the problem at hand it wasn't one
central problem as
we were kind of under the impression of
at the time uh but that was a huge
victory for us you know i i had somebody
kind of working uh with one of our more
senior devops
she ended up get developing very quickly
and i would say that was a major win for
us just be just because of the problem
at hand um you know the client was
exceptionally or exceptionally happy i
would say
once the issues were resolved they were
able to you know get on workbench
right to some shiny applications to link
back server
so it's happy it's a happy moment i
would say when you know
a very
simple problem it seems turns into a
little bit more of a challenge than you
expected and you're able to kind of you
know persevere um and get over kind of
the last step there making sure the
implementation is up to par uh and users
are happy with it with the end product
you delivered so as a company that was
something that i was exceptionally proud
of just
based on the difficulty of the
few issues at hand
thanks joe
another anonymous question from earlier
was for life sciences consulting what
are your thoughts on hiring people with
the relevant domain expertise if is it
important or not so important
yeah so i think right now we've just
been focusing on building out the
infrastructure there so we've been
targeting people with the domain
expertise for now um again kind of you
know somebody mentioned previously uh
struggling to find more senior people i
think you want to start with the senior
people that are willing to kind of take
on that leadership role potentially move
into
beyond the current technical uh lead
that they are at the point in their
career um but you know just
getting somebody in that's more senior
it has that domain expertise it helps
build a lot quicker than somebody you
know with a lot more variety maybe they
have some semblance of an idea of like
you know um
and some some rna-seq analysis some
something like that
uh but we we we looked to build out some
some junior people too but uh it starts
with building a firm foundation um
i always like to you know circle back to
understanding the foundational skill set
and building up from there um but you
need to have a firm base with what you
start with if you're looking to build
out that sector
thank you
sloan i see you just put a question into
the chat would you want to ask that one
live
sure sorry i had to
find my unmute button
anyways
so i work on a team uh data analytics
and data science team that's within it
uh and there's been some discussion on
moving us outside of i.t and i have seen
in the chat that there
are a lot of people talking about some
of the cons of being outside of i.t but
i guess i was curious about
some of the positives and i thought that
matthew's comment just under mine is a
very strong positive that i know that we
would probably benefit from
but i'm curious what other perspectives
are out there
sure um i mean oh cool cool
so most of my uh analytics has actually
been outside of i.t
um
been on a data science team of 15 people
um
some of the smaller ones but
[Music]
you need a strong leader
and
the most successful one that i've been
on
we had our own data engineering
resources
data science doesn't get done
without data engineering
and
i've been in organizations where
it's you don't even get any data
engineering support
and it's kind of a complete nightmare
you know they look at data sciences you
guys are just a corner case we're going
to take care of the rest of the
organization first and it's kind of like
well then
you're not going to get any innovation
or data science out of us then that's
sort of the reality of it
um and i've been in the middle of it too
so i've seen like
all three sides of that coin
and
it works extremely well as its own
organization
especially when you have someone on the
business side
or at least someone strong in the
business side and domain side
uh in charge
that has also a bit of the tech
background
um
because i've seen organizations where
you have a pure business person but they
don't really understand what everybody's
doing
um
and you know you explain to them look
this is really complicated this is a
mess or the data is a mess
um so it isn't you know you're not gonna
hear oh this will just take you and then
it's like yeah here we go
um you know there is that you know i'm
gonna select select star from perfectly
clean data set where everything is
perfect and i'm gonna do the analysis in
20 minutes
um
that doesn't exist but so i like it
outside of it i think there's a lot of
other stuff going on in it that you
don't need to be bothered with
thanks brian i i know joe you were about
to weigh in here as well if you have
other thoughts
um you know i see the pros and cons to
each situation here um i i like it uh
primarily working a little bit closer
especially people building out the
infrastructure um i think it's good to
kind of you know get a requirements
gathering session um and like the
continual integration continual
development right what are the pain
points in the system that we've
established already uh what needs to be
enhanced uh it it's hard to say from an
engineering perspective whether it's
kind of cost effective um unless you're
understanding a little bit about the
analysis techniques that are being
applied to the day-to-day work
my two cents there
thanks jeff
of course i love when people jump in
i
i have only been in analytics and data
science capacities outside of like
core i.t
um
and part of that is because most of my
experience is in like financial modeling
so
you know it's interesting
the like
projects where i feel data scientists or
you know analytics engineers within it
orgs the projects where they really
shine where you're like wow this is
an amazing concept that you guys have
implemented i feel like they're usually
more this is my experience feel like
they're usually more back end related
where
um
you know they're using ml or ai like in
a very advanced way
to make data more consumable for
you know the entire org including data
scientists
whereas
my experience being like
in these roles completely outside of it
i i kind of see that the focus is much
more on
some type of
visual
storytelling app or
you know presentation or something like
this so the nature of the like business
problems that we're trying to solve are
just inherently different
um
i tend to like
that aspect more because i really do
enjoy sort of the shiny app building or
like the visualization aspect of data
science
um but i've talked to others at my last
company especially who like had zero
interest in that they really
kind of thrived with more of like you
know the nlp or some of the back end
systems um
anyway just wanted to chime in with that
thank you
javier that's helpful i um
i see matthew you had some more thoughts
on this too if you want to add
into that
i'm happy to toil away in the background
of course but i i think um
something that's fun i was responding to
a comment from melody um
just in talking internally and having
these inside outside i.t functions
working with it um
my team we
recently stumbled on the phrase we refer
to ourselves as transformers and
thinking of uh it's actually you know
i'm not even close to an engineer but
electrical trend step up step down and
it's a way of leveraging the power of
data and technology to support decision
making by our subject matter experts and
business colleagues but also the other
way too we have an infamous case at my
organization asking about usage
information where there was a
head of our basically account management
out went directly to a database engineer
asking for usage information and you
know i have great respect for everybody
on all sides of this but it was a bit of
the old uh
adage of giggle garbage in garbage out
right she she got back a spreadsheet
that had usage data and said what am i
supposed to do with this
and so that's an infamous case here
where it's like okay the data science
team we come in and we understand we get
to an understanding of your problems
that you don't work directly with it
because then we can help shape and
standardize the problem to be able to
get closer to decision making and so
transformers were we're having a lot of
fun of it with it but not trying to
reference uh
any kind of recent movies with lens
flares or explosions
thanks matthew
people like that uh that transformers
concept
i uh
if sorry is it follows also they select
some of those keywords from
the
last
last few years will be have disruptive
technologies and
i think
my take is that traditional it
departments aren't suited for this
and
it's always better if you can do
something if you can
[Music]
if you can show something and produce a
little sort of nifty little product and
then show it show the ic department
look i can do this
then they can actually then take a step
they can hopefully take a step back and
say right
can we recognize whether this is can we
recognize how useful this is
and take a look inwards and say are we
the right sort of i.t organization
to be able to better support people like
this
i think traditionally
big it departments aren't appropriate
for this
and what you have to think about is
okay if we no longer have
if the big it department has become a
giant dinosaur by itself
can we think of something which will
better facilitate our people to do work
now that might mean creating better
communications
uh having more appropriate slack
channels having discussions and
having environments which is more
mentoring and helpful to people rather
than these big legacy monolithic
i.t departments
so
the question isn't whether or not you do
it inside or outside it you do it
if you if you find you can find a tool
which is useful to you use it
then maybe people can argue against why
you should why you should be doing
something different but you've at least
done your job
now
it should be the role of it departments
to be able to now help people do it more
efficiently and if they're not doing
that then they're not a good i.t
department
thank you steve
it's really helpful
i um
i know there's a lot of other thoughts
on this too i see matthew you just had
another
comment in the chat
sorry i've been away for a while and i
can't help myself but i was keyed off of
what steve was saying you know i hear
innovative and disruptive and well you
know we're not all steve jobs but we
have things to do and there's increments
to be made and i i actually have a i
have a substantive phd and there's an
xkd comic where it was like here's what
phd looks like it's this little pimple
on the surface of the sun it's like yup
that's you're advancing things and we're
not all going to make those huge jumps
but now
adopting from some product management
you know identifying okay everybody
wants that huge jump but we can deliver
value along the way while offering this
expertise
and you know then within my team we've
you know kind of stumbled on uh
beginning like prototyping showing
working with it and being like okay we
can do this as a shiny app or we can do
this this is a script that gets to like
the data artifact that we're talking
about and they say yeah yeah i can
understand that we've so we've
gotten to the business needs and the
supporting decision making and then
transform that and getting to these
small bits because it's like the whole
scale upgrade of our platform likely
can't happen anytime soon but we can
increase the value with these little
bits at a time and adopting like an mvp
mindset and collaborating that way is
starting to get some traction
thank you
i love this conversation happening right
now i know we're getting to the top of
the hour so i do want to make sure i
didn't miss any questions that came
through earlier in the chat or
on slido
so i'll give people a few seconds here
to raise your hand there was an
anonymous question i missed for you
uh earlier joe which was what do you do
for fun
oh what do i do for fun uh well you know
generally right now it's just a lot of
walking um i enjoy go and see in the sun
i throw a ball for a dog for a few hours
if i can find some time so
uh those are my those are my fun
activities right now just getting
outside enjoying some weather where it's
available
um
but other than that i you know it's
primarily just like wrapping up studies
right now for me
nice
and one other question for you joe um do
you have any podcasts or books or other
resources that you'd recommend for us or
things that you're you're checking out
now
uh
so i'll give you two two podcasts that i
really like um and maybe uh
one one's very math oriented i really
like the breaking math podcast um so
that's something that i would definitely
recommend um and then one one podcast
for more managerial stuff
my previous mentor recommended it it's
called manager tools
so totally recommend that one if you
haven't already seen it there's also um
an additional career tools uh so that
helps provide a little bit of guidance
for
uh you know individuals not necessarily
managers looking to advance their career
as well
awesome thank you i was trying to put
them into the
chat there before i
forget them but maybe i'm not putting
the right ones but i think they're right
but thank you all so much for joining
today thank you so much joe for
sharing your knowledge and insights with
us too
and caitlin thank you for joining i saw
your your comment in the chat your first
time here um glad to hear that you
enjoyed it and for anyone else who is
our first time here too we hope to see
you back as well thank you for joining
you